new revelations in a murder case against
two teens since destroyed the first
the i-team roof back in april a girl and
her boyfriend are accused of killing her
father
the i-team's vanessa murphy is here now
live with the latest
denise this is the first time we're
hearing about a video
a prosecutor says a video was found on
the 16-year-old girl's cell phone
in which the teens joke about killing
her father
a grand jury indicted sierra helseth and
her 18 year old boyfriend
aaron guerrero they're accused of
killing 45 year old daniel halseth
trying to dismember him and then setting
his body on fire
metro police say they fled on april 9
and they were arrested in utah on april
13th
according to detectives their parents
had previously told them they could no
longer see each other
and they plan to run away together to
california
they found a video clip where the two
defendants
are laying together and announced that
it's
this is their youtube channel and it's
been three days since the murder
and they kind of laugh about the fact
that aaron guerrero
committed the murder um in exchange
uh for i mean jokingly having sex with
uh sierra
halseth sierra halseth is also the
daughter of elizabeth houseth she
previously served as a nevada legislator
the teens are charged with murder
conspiracy to commit murder
arson credit card fraud robbery and
conspiracy to commit robbery
most of these charges are new through
the indictment
they remain in custody now with no bail
back to you
so vanessa you mentioned there that the
long list of charges credit card fraud
robbery charges what are those about
police say they used the victim's credit
card to purchase
saws and gloves at home depot and also
using his
debit card at atms and that they took
his
car back to you yeah that's very
disturbing details for sure vanessa
thanks for that